our next speaker is Bill mcclain and
who's the Halverson professor of
molecular biology at the University of
Wisconsin so bill is long used elegant
genetic about chemical approaches to
study the maturation of specific RNA
species in particular tRNAs and his
pioneering work defined the complex
multi-step pathway how it transcribed
DNA turns into mature tRNA he's also
made major contributions to our
understanding about the specificity
about how the DNA sequence is converted
into the amino acid sequence that
determines protein function which is
obviously a the fundamental process of
translation Sid and Bill were
postdoctoral fellows together with with
Sydney Brenner and francis crick in
Cambridge in the in the 1960s in the
began their work on T RNA processing at
that time and so bill is follow the
field very closely and as part of that
that interest in history he's written a
fantastic summary of SIDS discovery of
the enzymatic activity of RNA SP i
recommend it to all of you is in general
journal of molecular biology and i think
we'll have a little bit here a little
bit of that today as part of this talk
go
I want our no prettier I feel
particularly honored to be here today to
celebrate this great occasion of the
significant accomplishments of Sydney
Altman congratulations Sydney it's been
my great pleasure to know you for nearly
50 years and I'm among many
distinguished colleagues and I
appreciate that too I'm very humbled by
it today I'd like to talk about the
origin of life on the planet earth and I
hope to convince you the process is so
simple it's probably going to have
happened elsewhere in the universe and
beyond perhaps not generating human
beings but the mechanism by which the
code arose is extremely simple as we
understand it the RNA world generated
molecules became proteins and proteins
are the predominant are the so protein
molecules are the predominant
determinants of an organism's behavior
and shape and function and proteins
arise from the genetic code and transfer
RNA and I was thinking about the tool
and I think they're inextricably linked
neither the genetic code nor the
transfer RNA has any meaning biochemical
or genetic without the other just think
about that that's really true that
neither one has you neyo construct azum
without the other they they go in unison
and they make protein and that's what
I'm going to talk about today so i went
to the web right away when i was invited
to this and look what I found I found a
postage stamp celebrating 100 years of
the chemistry Nobel Prize and I think we
know this fellow right here he's sitting
in the front row over here at Sydney
Altman so congratulations Sydney again
yet again and also I found this slide
Sydney giving his Nobel lecture in
Stockholm and I found this there's his
Nobel Prize his metal his plaque and
each of the lawyers that year got a
painting a very beautiful original
painting and I'd like to point out one
thing tomm check tomm check was also
awarded the nobel prize for catalytic
RNA however only Sydney discovered an
enzyme Tom check discovered a catalyst
well suddenly discovered a special kind
of enzyme one that turns over multiple
times doesn't destroy itself and so I
think this is an enduring statement I
think all of you know this statement by
Francis Crick it's not escaped our
attention that the specific pairing we
have postulated suggests a possible
copying mechanism for the genetic
material that's the boy that's the
discovery of the DNA double helix in
1953 published in Nature is a two page
article and then some years later except
for a trivial reason novelty is the
trivial reason we should not be
surprised that RNA is an enzyme well
that's really great what a profound
statement so we have the genetic code 64
triplets we have transfer RNA they make
protein
this is the genetic code you see the
gold amino acids I'm going to try to
convince you today those were the first
five coded amino acids by an early
genetic code and it's so simple the way
they were found the way they were found
genetically prolene is a central player
and I'm going to tell you why probably
not you know from the Chow investment it
turns corners it's conformational space
is very limited so it's important to
make a hairpin why do you want to make a
hairpin I'll tell you why you want to
make a container for mass action reasons
so reactants can find each other
proximity and orientation this has never
been discussed previously so just a
brief review is to attach an amino acid
to transfer RNA you first activated with
an enzyme and amino acyl tRNA synthetase
which I abbreviate here is a ARS there
are 22 amino acids not when we were
students most of us anyway there were 20
since then cellino cysteine and pyro
lysine have been found so there's 22
amino acids each has its own synthetase
each has its own tRNA and there they're
activated so they can be transferred to
the end of the tRNA in an active form so
they're prepared for protein synthesis
the amazing thing that dino morass found
is there's two classes of aminoacyl-trna
synthetases and they approached the tRNA
molecule either from the left side and
this is the rossman fold parallel beta
strands and flanking alpha helixes and
this this is the right side this is the
the other the morass fold and it's anti
parallel beta strands and alpha helixes
in an approach it's a dimer these are
all monomers and this is a dimer you
know what dimerizes you know what the
key amino acid is prolene prolene is the
key amino acid
I'm rice without if you don't dimerize
you don't amino acyl ate the tRNA
substrate and there's a ten members of
this class and ten members of that class
it's really remarkable it's 10 of each
this is at the beginning of life this
happened back way back at the beginning
and has been maintained look at the
tRNAs they attach these synthetases I've
kind of flipped them this class one here
attaches setia the amino acid to the two
prime hydroxyl of the terminal adenosine
of the ribose ribose of the adenosine
and class to attach it to the three
prime hydroxyl now going into the
ribosome they have to be on one
particular site and there's a way to
convert that ef-tu catalyzes that
reaction but this is a remarkable really
that all all systems all genetic systems
that are known proceed this way so
here's here's there's ten members I
haven't put the other two of the the two
that are missing belong in this class
too and here are the 5 i'm going to tell
you where the original 500 bear arianny
and this is a student a dino morass he
was a graduate student and mark Delarue
was the person who had the real insight
they certain they found this prolene
separated by arginines with a certain
number of residues between them and that
was sufficient to pull out from the PDB
ten proteins and there were all these
class two synthetases and then so here
here we have this probably more than a
thousand pdb files of class one with the
rossman fold dinucleotide reductase
parallel beta strands but there's only
12 there's only 12 of these this is the
original this is good I'm going to try
to convince you this is the original
synthetase the way it worked was by
separating the strands to look inside an
a form helix you can't see the edges of
the basis on any forum helix so it ran
out of space you open your separate
strands pretty soon you run out of space
for specificity for adding new amino
acids so you got to figure out another
way and that's when the class that's
where class one came in now in 1988 by
computer analysis i identified a subset
of nucleotides for each of the 20 tRNAs
by I mean me and my group Hugh Nicholas
a statistician I had a half a dozen
statisticians a subset of nucleotides
and we found four alanine tRNA and
e.coli that a GU pair was distinctive of
but Nepal Schimmel working independently
with yuming how made a similar
observation that a GU wobble pair near
the three-prime acceptor end was
responsible for the acceptor activity so
this is the standard clover leaf
structure of a tRNA and this is sticking
from our science publication there's the
GU pair now originally Francis script
used introduced the term wobble it was
an information exchange group I EG do
any of you remember those you got them
free from nih just send it in so he it
was information exchange group and then
it was published in a journal Molecular
Biology we see at the top here the
standard to Watson Crick Paris you see
the glycosidic bond the the same angle
you can flip them and the perpendicular
to the axis 90 degrees whereas the
watson-crick bear the g goes down into
the minor groove reducing this
glycosidic bond angle and the u.s.
pushed up into the major groove
increasing that angle so Paul Schimmel's
interpretation is that the enzyme the
amino acyl synthetase is just looking
for this amino group in the minor groove
you get three kilocalories from that
interaction and the specificity for
aminoacylation just the first step is 10
to the mine is done to the minus 3 it
don't mean the error rate it's 10 to the
minus 3 from 3 kilocalories it's not
possible it's so we had a different
interpretation and ours was the GU cause
the helical irregularity that
irregularity is what I'm going to
about for the remainder of the talk this
is published again at 88 we we knew
right away the minute we saw gu we knew
Francis's the structure we also know
that Oh canard showed that AC was I
cement I so steric with GU in that the a
is pushed into the minor groove in the
UN to the major group she was studying
DNA she was interested in me to Genesis
so this paper was published several
years later Paul Schimmel criticized our
work very certainly he said you can't
trust genetics you know you can get
these serendipitous reactions and
serendipitous results that we have
nothing to do with biochemistry so what
we did is we translocated this GU pair
to an adjacent site so if GU is causing
a helical regularity then if you
transfer it it should retain some of its
function right on the other hand if the
protein is looking for that two amino
group at a specific spot it might not
work it's going to be moved four or five
angstroms away so here's the result we
had this was done with a nonsense
suppressor reporter protein with the
marker there nonsense mutation of
position three this is the read off from
the protein sequence Matheny enter
monomyth irony I salute a hundred
percent a linear at the third position
by translocating the GU from position 3
to 4 so clearly this supports our
proposal at the time and we've
subsequently done a lot more i'll show
you a crystal structure that will
convince you still more now we had this
sequence for 30 years and i noticed once
when i was very ill I had a hip replaced
after waiting 30 years look at this GU
here but look what precedes GCU you know
what that is that's an alanine codon and
it turns out that last you is part of
the GU pair that determines
in going on the end of the tRNA well
what a coincidence what a coincidence so
I've noted that here so G C you actually
GC n where n is any of the four
nucleotides makes an alanine codon and
then on the other strand you so you read
the codons five prime to three prime you
all know that of course at a hundred and
fifty-eight bacterial and archaeal
alanine sequences to see how frequently
we found GU at this site here and then
subsequently we looked over here to see
what was there here's what we found at
this this position here with the G at
this position here or the GU you see
what we found here is I have to come
around here to read this we find Syrian
wonderful hydroxyl group we find alanine
we find glycine a great turner to turn a
helix to make a hairpin prolene the
interface of the dimer of the the
synthesis of course this is the evolved
synthetase two people in the audience
know that the tripeptide and terminal
prolene prolene threonine will catalyze
an aldol condensation reaction with the
same cake at and km as a 400 amino acid
residue protein well the person the two
people that discovered that got a nobel
prize in chemistry in about two thousand
and one so protein is pretty important
to have it you know not only dimer
interface but it was catalytically
active very early on and we see another
your three need there's a hydroxyl group
you'll see in an aspartic acid and then
it a syntactically approaches 0 and then
if we look on the other strand it's
running in the opposite direction so you
would expect different amino acids but
here we find again we find alanine and
glycine ism
major players here really quite
surprising as I said we had this in
front of us for 30 years and never never
paid any attention to it so we wanted to
ask are these two distributions
different statistically obviously
visually input impression istic Lee
they're different but we wanted we
subjected it to statistical analysis so
hypothesis a histograms represent the
same distribution and that's the null
hypothesis and then hypothesis be there
different distributions and we found
that the the null hypothesis is rejected
in the problem the risk associated with
rejecting that is 45 hundredths percent
so they're really now statistically
different I don't pressure mystically
different but they're statistically
different so now john sutherland MRC lmb
current guy he got the Gregor Mendel
award by the way from England for this
work what he's found is that all the
reactants that were necessary to start
like for president at the same time
under this with cyanide they didn't
appear one at a time but they were all
present this was published in nature but
Patel southern this john sutherland is
the last author the last author so the
arriving nucleotides the amino acid slip
his lipids were very important and so my
quieres here he shown just with a 29
nucleotide RNA right here you see that
this is an acid gel and has to gel so
this is diesal trna and this species
migrating more slowly is this strand
right here with phenylalanine it's been
attached to it by this 29 nucleotide RNA
it runs slower because of the increased
mass from the phenylalanine and then the
positive charge on the amino group makes
it run slower in the gel so not only
where they were actin stare but they
were active there you know so here we
have a
Oh length polysaccharides southern and
found the precursor to this well how
could they act they could write here
they could attach serine and threonine
by their hydroxyl groups to this well
why is that important they could make a
cage what's the cage good for its
precursor to a cell for two molecules to
react they have to be in proximity and
they have to have the right orientations
it has to be something before the cell
is very complex so what came before the
cell a cage probably formed through
threonine and serine attaching to the
lipid and they were in a hairpin loop
with a prolene kinking the peptide as we
understand it from current protein
structure that's a hypothesis of course
and so I've just put these little hair
pins down here and you'll note that this
is a I call it a linear proxy we have
tRNA la knockout cells and so we're able
to isolate a variance of the tRNA and
the variance again now we see here they
have glycine proline here glycine
searing and prolene they still code for
the same amino acids so here we have the
these are the five of protein these five
amino acids that were first coated they
can be they all can be accommodated by
just G and C so maybe the early codon
was just G and C and later incorporated
a in you so starting with eight codons
instead of the 64 2 to the third is a 2
to the third power is 8 and you can get
the other two introduced just into
figlio generations by incorporating miss
appear wobble pairing you can get a ga
period with the you and a parent with C
so it's possible to get from this to the
64 now in these knockout cells that we
made we found the most active variant
the most active variant when you
take when you substitute GU is CC who
would ever guess that you can't do this
in a knockout cell because the anticodon
in a knockout self it's a it's going to
go to glutamine or lysine as an opal
suppressor but we found this it's almost
the same as wild-type so my my colleague
at the MRC LM at the lmb Gabriel
varieties of spectroscopy and so he
determined the NMR structure of this
tetra loop first he did the wild-type
tetra loop and then he did the tetra
loop with the CC did in collaboration
with us and so this is this is the NMR
spectrum of the CC tetra loop and you'll
see the base pairs the the entire
structure is identical for this CC tetra
loop except for the CC it's in rapid
equilibrium milli second to micro second
time scale that means it's coming apart
you know it hasn't got a defined
structure he lowered the pH to
stabilized base to try to see possible
base pair interactions the helix fell
apart well just think about this
beginning of protein coding if the helix
can come apart that'd be a great way for
a synthetase to inspect so there are urs
or glory they came apart now this is B
form DNA this is the famous Watson Crick
and you see how the bases if we if we if
we look here this is the helical axis
the bases are at 90 degrees well to that
in a form aren't this is an a for mrna
helix the base the edges of the bases
aren't exposed so it's not possible for
a synthetase to look and discriminate
between different potential except ters
because that you have to take a you have
to take the strands apart at least
partially to look it to have a look at
them to see what they are
but helix opening thermodynamic
stability is not sufficient in itself
strand separation is not sufficient and
of itself to specify or to get amino
acid Ellen attached because we have GU
with a TM of 87 GC it's a hundred
century this is act of mutant this is
suppressing nonsense of presser
efficiency 80 degrees in here CC 78 here
you have you see it's inactive still has
this low TM so strand separation isn't
sufficient in itself it's much more
complicated than that so the local local
separation of the strands then is
probably what's happening then I had a
student hunt sick Choi who made a
library with using knockout cells where
he randomized all these positions all
these positions are important for the
trna alanine to accept alanine left this
one alone this is where our nay speak
leaves we didn't want to fool with it
and it got this remarkable mutant right
here it's shown in red all these bases
changed this this is mutant called 71 it
has the same growth properties as the
wild-type tRNA changing all those
nucleotides well they must act as a
group they must act as a group the
minute I saw it I'm sure hun sick
realizes he wouldn't talk he grew up
within a mile with DMZ he wouldn't say
anything he was thought you survived
there by saying nothing so I told him to
change each one of these bases
individually back to the wild-type base
here when he did that it killed it just
as if you were mutating the white the
wild-type tRNA from eight to Asik you
kill that so these are acting as a
cooperative unit way that's all we knew
we didn't know more than that but you
never you never learn this by doing
single nucleotide mutagenesis you
wouldn't learn it from doing crystal
crystallography either of a synthetase
trna parent you wouldn't know that these
nucleotides were acting as a cooperative
unit
so Yuki Dino morass and I tried really
hard to get a crystal structure so this
is the class these are the 10+2
synthetases you see in there they're
super positioned on their superimposed
on the synthetase and the trna here's
all the nine of the tears alanine over
here it's so different from the rest the
other class to synthetases and now i'll
show you in the next the last slide the
helical associative irregularity that
we're talking about the yellow is the
yellow is the backbone of the free trna
uncharged you see a clash is with the
synthetase but in the tea in the form
that's bound to the synthetase right
here the amino a so for me the major
groove is widened by as much as almost
three angstroms that's a gigantic a base
pair of aces 33.4 angstrom since it's a
gigantic gets all along the helix all
the way this all seven base pairs in the
stem and into the tea stem so now that's
why I say the genetic code tRNA protein
synthesis are inextricably linked and so
the last question I didn't know that
matt meselson was going to talk about
sex but Sydney asked me the question
where did the codons come from francis
crick says you can't pose the right
question until you're near the answer
well we think we know where the eggs
came from what did the egg come before
the chicken which came first the chicken
or the egg it's really really a profound
question if the egg came first wanted to
come from if the chicken came first how
did that how did that because it how did
that happen what we're on to that we're
on to that now I'll hope to talk to you
again in the future my collaborators you
Nicholas postdoc for ten years with the
Pittsburgh supercomputer center after
that and now he's back as a postdoc in
guy Plunkett got his
agree with me he's at the genome center
he collected all those sequences hundred
there's so many errors in the tRNA
sequence in the database to DNA and RNA
is so many errors you got to be an
experienced person and so without him
this project would not have happened and
incredible financial support from the
National Institutes of Health general
medical scientist and then of course my
stipend at the president I momentum
emeritus professor and I'd like to thank
you for your attention thank you i'll
tell you the story i'll tell you know i
wanted to i want to answer that question
you do the experiments before you get
the answer and then you write the
proposal as if you hadn't done the
experiment so then in the study section
when they review your your continuation
application they see you've done
everything you said you're going to do
but you've done it ahead of time of
course you have to have a running start
so to speak the study section says they
already know it yeah don't don't propose
an experiment is too good that they're
never going to forget it you know if you
know if you haven't unless you've
already done it I once made a proposal a
really a clever experiment but it just
wasn't feasible because nucleic acid
basis they don't they have a preference
who their neighbor is in the helix the
rules for this aren't known but I'll
tell you it's not it's not they don't
find they have a basis they like to be
next to and bases they like they dislike
to be next to those rules having the
physical chemists haven't figured that
out yet we tried to overcome it when we
made these libraries we couldn't do it
IDT you know just GNA since the RNA
synthesized you can't get a random
sequence we couldn't we tried hard no
I'm when you make a synthetic RNA when
you order from machine chemically
synthesized you put in an order you
don't get back what you
order I'm telling you it's not a random
distribution some basis don't like to be
next to that probably underlies part of
the genetic code if that's your question
distribution the vfo yes amino acids and
whole protein so the question is given
my claim that some basis don't like to
be next to others wouldn't that impact
the distribution of amino acids that we
see in the jury of course it would but
what would you like to predict what that
is well if that would be you first have
to know what the rules are the rules
aren't known there's not many people
that are aware of this you know no no
I'm talking about message I'm talking
about genome sequences I'm talking you
know if all DNA all RNA this is not
limited just the tRNA
you